[Applause]
yeah thanks so much for being here see
you so much for having me yes
congratulations on so much you got mr.
robot yeah love that show gradually I
loved it and great reviews for king
cobra right no it's really good Thank
You Man and we got to talk about this
king cobra yes you and James Franco
right you play gay pornographers
is that correct gay person each with no
that's that's the characters gay
pornographers each with young actor love
interests I believe we have a poster
here from the ARV so this is I mean
there are for you and James Franco
there are same-sex love scenes correct
and so I'm curious how do you as an
actor how do you approach that that's
good it's it's fascinating it was just
touch my nipple
[Applause]
that's how you do it so that's how you
do I tell you guys you know I'm a very
good act you're really good you you have
jumped right in traffic because of that
that's amazing he's very shy you know I
just got out of the seminary I don't
think I gotta like feel the fear and do
it anyway that's yeah so I got through
it really do it feel the fear yeah but
it's it I would say as an actor that's
that's very challenge it was no it
definitely was when James Franco asked
me if I'd be interested in in doing this
project I read it and I went mmm
wow I really do have to think about this
this is definitely out of my wheelhouse
I did have a lot of anxiety and fear
about doing something like this but then
I just say I'm an actor you know and III
asked my wife and and she said no you
should absolutely go do it so I had her
support and I I dove right in that's not
seems like you should absolutely
those men I don't know what's going on
yeah excited really now and then I had
Garrett Clayton who's the young man on
the poster there and you know the kid is
beautiful that's your love interest in
that yeah that's my guy that's that he's
the he's the discovery that I make yeah
I meet him and I sort of lure him into
my organization called Cobra films and
he becomes this great huge discovery and
James Franco plays the guy who works for
this other company called the Viper Boys
and he tries to come after my guy and I
don't want to release him and it becomes
a story of obsession and control and of
course eventually at the end it's also
based our true story right so it's it
gets a little dark at times
you